seis candidatos se disputan dos puestos
para una prácticamente segura segunda
vuelta electoral los sondeos sitúan en
cabeza a yonhy lescano del
centroizquierda acción popular es el
único que superaría ligeramente el 10
por ciento de voto forma parte del
partido de manuel merino uno de los
cuatro presidentes que ha tenido perú en
los últimos cuatro años su período fue
de ciento días pensamos que esta
economía hacia una economía liberal sin
límite sin sensibilidad muy cerca de
sigue a hernando de soto de avanza país
economista de derecha con experiencia
internacional ha conseguido un aumento
en la intención de voto en las últimas
semanas porque es una persona un
profesional ha ayudado a muchos países a
desarrollarse yo creo que no puede
apoyar a nosotros los peruanos desde un
país grande también ha estado creciendo
en los sondeos verónica mendoza de la
coalición de izquierda juntos por perú
quien busca que el país forme parte de
una nueva izquierda latinoamericana que
nuestra campaña
ustedes ven aquí no está pagado nuestra
financiada auto considerado de centro se
encuentra georges forsythe del partido
victoria nacional así se presenta hijo
de un padre diplomático por lo cuál
creció en muchos países también jugador
de fútbol profesional de ex seleccionado
del perú también tiene posibilidades una
candidata conocida keiko fujimori del
derechista fuerza popular es la
representante del fujimorismo iniciado
por su padre el ex presidente alberto
fujimori ha estado tres veces en prisión
preventiva acusada de corrupción
nosotros lo que hablamos es de trabajar
para recuperar la vida y la salud la
vida y la economía de todos los peruanos
más descolgados en las encuestas está el
ultraderechista rafael lópez aliaga
cercano al opus dei- puede dar muy
tranquilo mi casa pero me convierte
pleito por el bien del perú pero no va a
ser de verdad sobre mi cadáver la
corrupción la pobreza y la falta de
representatividad son señaladas como las
causas del que es quizá el principal
rasgo de esta elección el desinterés de
los votantes